[Applause]
did you have that set up the rock is
that what you wanted
you ask questions and I answer them this
is the ask Gary be shut up
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and you're listening and
watching to episode number 69 right is
that we're on yeah
69 of the ask gary vee show this episode
is extremely special because this is a
vaynermedia employee episode i assume
but have an idea you like blasted out
the company who's got questions and
these four wonderful people have in your
opinion the best ones and then the rest
of the people that are in the audience
were not as best but good but good good
enough good enough at least be in the
audience is that what happened good so
india hurt feelings we've got some LA
and SF questions and i'm excited about
this episode so let's get into the show
hi my name probably go are we on I'm a
man why don't you tell the Vayner nation
who you are what you do here how long
you've been at Vayner and then uh then I
will be ready for your question oh so
hey everybody I'm Jordan I'm a project
manager here I've been here for a little
over a year maybe a year and a half and
I got a question for you Gary
hey that's what I figured that is it is
the askgaryvee show um now I'm giving
you a statement Gary show ya
can we register I'm giving you a
statement Gary calm okay can we get on
that thank you
um I'm a huge fan of like long-form
media okay just medium play rock like
movies no mainly on sites or like dogs
like when birds write to 7,000 pay the
word expose yeah okay vice big bad fan
okay what do you feel is like the next
best way to monetize off those sites so
beyond sponsored content beyond
placements how could someone who writes
that make money you know I think that
that's a good question so you're saying
if you were to start a long-form media
company and you hired journalists and
and your spin was anti let's call it
BuzzFeed and it was the other direction
back to the old days of journalism but
from a digital standpoint are you saying
to me the mix of that and BuzzFeed is
he's been interesting to me are you
saying what if I just went in that whole
direction of just that like if like if
the site put out three to four long
pieces of content day is that where
you're going you know to me obviously
sponsored content would work uh you know
obviously people will still sell banners
and things of that nature against those
things but if you want to go in
different direction
there's a couple places to go first and
foremost I actually think events is a
sneaky thing I don't think people
recognize or understand recode or
TechCrunch or Mashable how much money
they actually make on event arbitrage
versus ad revenue so I think that's one
way to go I also think the Keystone
sponsor is something that people haven't
thought enough about so imagine world if
you were the modern-day Sports
Illustrated with long form and you know
and Pepsi was your anchor sponsor almost
like for anybody who watches ESPN I've
been fascinated by thirty four thirty
the documentary series where the brand
comes in and says this thirty four
thirty was brought to you by Levi's and
then that's it um I think there's a real
play that if you show quality and
there's a brand wanting to be associated
with it
where there's just one anchor brand that
owns let's call it like a stadium naming
rights like if I was starting something
like that I'd go out and try to sell my
thing upfront to a huge brand for three
years as the anchor sponsor period
actually think television over the next
decade as they start struggling with
monetizing commercials you're gonna see
a lot more product integration but all
of us are cynical to product integration
I think if you you know for a lot of you
watch you know when you watch TV there's
the you know NBC or Fox logo I think
it's a there's a substantial chance that
in the next decade when you're watching
a TV show you'll see the Fox logo but
you'll also see on the other side the
Bud Light logo and they'll be there the
entire time and it's a you know it's a
college show right so to me the keynote
the kind of a Keystone sponsor to me
there's doing events around it and so
what would that look like it depends on
genre I guess and so those are the two
things that really most standout for me
I also think media companies and
agencies are combining I think one of
the weird ways to subsidize and make
money
is if your sports illustrated's playing
here and then you're producing content
around sports for brands and I do think
that that is what vice and Busbee and
refinery29 are doing and so that's my
answer
okay they should be in our show yeah say
goodbye thanks for having me
[Applause]
next are we gonna listen to it we're
gonna go to uh yeah yep well you can sit
here India oh geez hey lady
mash is roughly what percentage of your
business decisions are based on a gut
feeling versus being backed by actual
data that's a very good question um I
think all of my strategy is completely
intuition because if you look at my
20-year career most of it has been
guessing I'd like to think projecting
where the markets gonna go and there was
no data on what ecommerce would do in
1996 there was no data on email
marketing when you're one of the first
hundred people that's doing email
marketing there was no data on the ROI
of
Twitter four or five months after
Twitter came out and you're starting to
use it for marketing there was no data
on what a YouTube show less than a year
after YouTube came out was going to
bring in value there was no data on what
Instagram was going to bring us in value
and AJ sold brisk iced tea at Instagram
campaign 13 days after Instagram had
come out there's no data around what
vine celebrities would mean when we
started a vine agency 110 days after
vine came out so from a strategy
standpoint I mean truly I believe that I
get the accolades and have the luxury of
doing a show that people actually want
completely on intuition because that's
what I have that other people don't have
it's no different than being great at
basketball or being attractive or all
the other good things that can happen in
life it's just they're right it was just
always there and so that's my X Factor
now I think that is equally then 50%
quantified against data right so I make
these predictions but
to run an actual business this is where
my practicality gets underestimated you
know this company grew very quickly you
don't do that if you can't make payroll
right there's a lot of practicality that
goes into running a business and so you
know for me I've always thought I was a
super 5050 guy obviously my my
personality and communication style gets
most people's attention and they bucket
me in to that kind of place
but I think enormous pride out of the
fact that you know for the first ten
years of my professional career I didn't
say a single word to anybody about
anything and all I did was execute and
I'll be very honest with you it's been
extremely gratifying to me to shut up
all the people that thought when I was
building vaynermedia that I missed a lot
of Twitter followers like there was
substantial amount of buzz when I
started vaynermedia of like oh the
social media guru thinks he can build an
agency and now building one of the
biggest and fastest growing agencies of
all time and sticking that directly in
their throat feels tremendous you like
that sure all right hey hey wait how are
you good yeah we need pom-poms hi Gracie
I have to tell you I'm super excited to
be on the show because I watched every
single episode and I was laughing
because I think was episode 67 you asked
where do you watch the show and I was
kind of laughing because I've watched it
literally like walking down the sidewalk
like stepping over a dog like in the
shower brushing my teeth like just
however you can consume it's the one
thing I don't miss every day raise let's
give this wonderful let's talk about her
raise all right tell the vaynernation
who you are animation I'm Whitney I'm an
Account Manager here at Vayner and
February February 10th will be my
one-year anniversary awesome so my
question is do you prefer to be around
people who are the same as you are or
who are different for you that's a good
question um same or different you know
what's interesting I had an interesting
moment maybe five or six years ago where
I was questioning if I was surrounding
myself with yes men and women right like
people that were just shaking their head
if I started noticing it and other what
people and my friends and I thought that
that was super dangerous and I couldn't
really figure out if I was surrounding
myself with yes people or that that I'm
so forceful of my opinions that I leave
no oxygen in the room for anything else
but I think you know it's funny like you
know Steve for example right I would you
know and we've referenced this in the
past and Steve and I talked about this
like I like that Steve you know I think
now he almost does it as a stick because
I think he but but that being said right
India Thank You India
thanks for the confirmation but you know
I take a lot of prot pride in in really
valuing other people like I'm I think
I'll it for as much as I talk which is
constantly and for as much in a meeting
for an hour and a half that I could talk
the entire time and not nobody else can
get a word in you know I think I listen
quite a bit and I listen in a lot of
different ways having a one-hour meeting
where you like listen is very different
than what I'm actually doing which is
when I actually spend time with
everybody here or in the world that's
actually my time to talk because every
other minute I'm listening every other
minute I'm looking at what my employees
are putting on Instagram from a selfie
standpoint you know you know every other
minute I'm looking at what people are
favoriting or consuming or when I walk
through here looking at what they're
looking at in their screen if they're
not working are they reading reddit are
they watching YouTube videos you know uh
you know the vaynernation knows this and
you've watched a show you know this I'm
critiquing the [ __ ] out of them like I'm
again I think what it's all said and
done I'd like to think maybe this is
what I'm projecting but I know that I'm
doing the reverse of what a lot of
people think I'm doing and so when I'm
with people I'm talking a whole lot
because it's my time to take what I've
gathered throughout every other minute
that's going on in the world to execute
again so you know I to me it's just a
people in that game I love being around
people that are like me
the truth is back to being an anomaly I
don't meet that many people that I think
are really similar to me and that's
probably a good thing for the world you
know I find most people are different
than me I definitely feel like from
where the markets going 90% 95% the
market doesn't see or agree with me and
I'm happy that 80% of time I think I'm
right on those things long term but I
just like people in general and so I to
me a good solid debate is equally sexy
to yes in each other and just glorifying
how awesome we are that we see this or
agree on this issue they're weirdly one
in the same very cool cool thanks who's
in that room and why this alone no
worries yeah cool Wow I know but Susan's
projects Jeff gates so good with the
shoes is he Joe Namath amazing
oh hi Gary I have a question
nationwide CMO recently justified their
Superbowl ad by saying we weren't trying
to sell insurance you're trying to save
children's lives how do you feel about
advertising such a somber spot in the
Superbowl great question and great legs
Jeff liked my joke
uh you know that's a really good
question you know it's really
interesting I always have wondered if
everybody talking the next day after the
Super Bowl about the monkey that jumped
on the bear with the cute little like
puddle of water with a smiley face on it
did that actually help XYZ things sell
its thing and you know I think at some
level we have a lot of wannabe you know
movie producers making TV commercials
for the Super Bowl and it's their chance
to do the most creative thing that
they've always wanted to do and like
they're so happy I actually weirdly I'm
pretty Pro that commercial spot and I'll
explain why number one at some level
advertising supposed to make you
remember and think and and recall and
the truth is that piece of content makes
me think about what those people
actually do for a living a hell of a lot
more than a lot of other things where
people bring back old-school celebrities
and then like 10 minutes later you don't
even know which snack it really was or
which soda was or which beer it was and
so you know I understand people's
pushback against it but I'm a humongous
fan of going countercultural right and
so in a world of like Super Bowl is
festive and this and that and
everybody's kind of going for humor you
know I mean here we are talking about it
right and so again I was at the Super
Bowl and and haven't fully even seen the
spot and don't have all the context so
I'm not super prepared to give my final
final final answer on this and I'll try
to do that shortly because I should be
on top of something like that but my
early intuition is that there's a lot of
value to always playing the other side
of the equation and from what I can tell
without seeing fully the spot because
I've seen the images but not fully the
spot the content is at least closely
tied in to what that company does for a
living and I think that way too many
people want to throw Betty White out
there or a cute Xyz kitty cat or
something that nature and you just you
talking about this the creative but you
have no interest in going and buying the
product
you know I thought it would I think
there's real potential for that kind of
effectiveness so I think standing out
and going in the other direction is
always the right thing in a crowded
environment and I think they've clearly
done that because everybody's still
talking about it and a lot and debating
it and it's tied in to the business they
actually do so ji-sub buddy how are you
good are you gonna see man see you
what's up everybody I'm Steve Campbell
d-roc you can link that up right here
I'm a copywriter here at Vayner been
here about four and a half years oh gee
baby oh gee so I've always wanted a
Steelers fan Steelers fan gotta get that
out there one of our rare wins this year
for the Jets yeah unfortunately I
remember that so I watched you answer
dozens literally dozens of questions
over the years about everything from
family to business to wine I was always
curious what is one question that you're
shocked nobody's ever asked you before
that's a good question
the truth is people have asked me this
exact question before I guess it's never
been on film and since I've answered
thousands of questions not dozens maybe
um the funny thing is even though I
think I get I get a lot of credit for
being able to answer questions
immediately when I don't know what they
are and they come from so many different
directions there I'm trying to figure
out the psychology behind this answer it
is very intriguing to me that I don't
know how to answer this question at all
right that I don't know if I'm so pure
about loving Q&A that like like I don't
even know like I'm never prepared for a
question there's nothing I you know look
I definitely don't struggle with telling
the world things that I want to say so
there's no question I need for me to be
able to communicate something that I
want to say you know for a little while
there and I think the askgaryvee show
has helped it and definitely that post I
did the other day about like here's how
you build your personal brand and it was
like - shut the [ __ ] up for ten years
and build something I do I don't think
it's that
it's not that I'm surprised nobody's
ever asked me questions i I do wish that
more people asked me hardcore business
building questions I think that people
want to go towards the motivation and
the vision and things of that nature but
like like hardcore tactical like how do
you staff you know like against a pianet
like the stuff that I actually do that's
super nerdy I mean I'm sure the reason
people don't ask me it is because it is
super nerdy it's not as sexy it's not
the sizzle it's clearly the boring slab
of steak but for me I take so much pride
in being an operator I take enormous
pride and being able to build two
businesses now in a young business
career that is that have both grown from
a small base to 50 million dollars in
revenue in 36 months that just doesn't
happen a lot especially in a non funded
environment neither come money to do it
so it was all its own growth and using
its own cash flow to do which makes the
3 year growth so much more difficult so
I guess I guess I'm not doing a good
enough job portraying that part of my
career to induce that type of audience
to ask me those kind of questions oh
well so first and foremost thank you so
much for being here guys
thanks for being part of today's show
that was super fun episode 69 in the bag
let's clap it up for yourselves I love I
love when I ask people to clap for
themselves or something I'm super oh
yeah I don't know I love it
question of the day uh what question
would you really like to ask me based on
Steve's last question that you've never
asked me meaning can you come up with an
interesting question for me you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
yeah
ever yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah